let's get to bs or [ __ ]
okay you're allowed to swear don't worry
i don't like this word so i'm going to
say bs well technically it's not
swearing it's just well guaranteed but
that's okay
i'm going to say what i think it is
because i'm trying to make sure i
understand and then you'll just correct
me okay so
bs it's not necessarily you're lying to
yourself or someone's lying to you
it's when there's the
inappropriate hijacking of salience from
something like a relevance
landscape or habit yeah that is
that makes conspicuous something that's
irrelevant yeah in an important way
um i think that's right um i would i
would add a bit more to it and i i would
put it in sort of
uh the sort of the the notion comes from
frankfurt
harry frankfurt and his seminal essay on
[ __ ] which is like 20 years old now
um it's fairly new because most of these
ideas 100
they're like nietzsche yeah jung yeah so
that's pretty new frankfurt's really
important uh modern philosopher
um and so frankfurt was uh
he starts the book in a way that of
course is ultimately deeply relevant to
the meaning crisis because one symptom
of the meaning crisis is
he says you know there's this there's a
sense of just increasing amounts of
[ __ ]
um and then he said you know if if
that's the case
i'm paraphrasing him of course he says
not verbatim but if that's the case
you know we we got to get clear about
what bullshitting is and he then
tries to distinguish it from lying and
he says the liar works by trying to get
you to believe in the truth of something
right and so the liar is depending on
altering your behavior
because you care about truth right so i
tell you that susan loves you even
though she doesn't because that's what
what yeah so i do that
and i can change your behavior
now what the [ __ ] artist does
according to frankfurt
is they get you to become indifferent to
the truth and then
there's i think the following thing i'm
going to say is implicit in frankfurt
but part of what i've done is sort of
explicate it make it more explicit i
think that what the [ __ ] artist does
then
is not only make you indifferent to the
truth they make you indifferent to the
truth as you said
by trying to make something
inappropriately salient and catchy to
you
as a way of manipulating your behavior
and part of what i think that
inappropriateness
means is that the salience has been
right how you're tracking salience has
been uncoupled
by how you're trying to determine the
truth of things
so one of my standard examples is as i
give it's like
part of me the simpsons oh i wasn't
going to do the simpsons but i could do
the simpsons one of my standard examples
another one is um
is um is advertising
so like you go into you watch it first
while you watch a commercial right
and you know a person's in a bar and
they get some alcohol which of course
they don't actually drink but they
alcohol and then there's attractive
people come around and everybody's
smiling and laughing
and you know that's not true you just
you go into a bar that's not what
what's going on there and you know it's
not true and they know you know it's not
true but you know what they're doing
they're making that alcohol
very super salient to you because you
have attractive people
you've got nice lighting that's 90 of
ads yes and so 90
of ads are basically [ __ ] and do the
ads make you
not believe in truth at all or do they
just make something salient
and you still care about the truth well
so doesn't it it doesn't actually
besmirch your truth seeking that's a
good
good metaphor um now that's a really
tricky question
i mean so i i can't give like a yes
no answer to it right i think
so in the instance what happens there is
of course and this is why the
advertisers do it you buy the product
right you buy the product largely
independent of sort of your assessment
of the truth uh it's they're counting on
impulse buying
uh for a lot of what you do um you know
you're walking
in it it jumps off the shelf at you kind
of thing that's what salience is
things stand out for you right now your
question i want to i want to pause on it
because i think it's it's a question
that deserves reflection
it's like how often do you have to cycle
through this where you
are disconnected from truth you become
let's use the right word here
indifferent it drops into the background
it's not sailing it to you it's not
motivationally
you know uh affecting you how often
it when you disconnect from that and
allow yourself to be caught up in
salience does does it have to go on
before this this gains enough autonomy
that it becomes compelling and difficult
for you to return
to the truth tracking uh because
obviously that can happen
and cults are an example of that of
course it can magicians are an example
to me of someone who's a self-admitted
[ __ ] artist yes so they'll tell you
i'm doing
i'm this is all [ __ ] yeah you want
to play the game of watching and being
interested
but at the end you know it's [ __ ]
but the advertisers advertisers won't
tell you
it's bs because maybe in an interview
later they'll say it's bs
they they typically won't do that well
if they're trying to make a joke
well the joke will be they'll in fact
some advertising
works with the joke of you know that's
not true
i know it you know it's not and they'll
they'll give you the conceit
that you are smart because you know it's
not true well the and
the trouble with that if right what's
problematic about that
is by appealing to your sense
of excellence like this is the
superiority illusion
most people believe they're above the
average uh in all dimensions which of
course is false it has to be false
right but because they're appealing to
that so the pro
that the the situation in which they
appeal to your sense of superiority
because you know the advertisement isn't
true precisely makes the product
salient to you so that you are more
likely to buy the product
um so yeah this this can and this
can and is becoming increasingly
sophisticated is bs related to trigger
words
like this is getting a little bit
political but redefine like racism
and and not oppression actually violence
is another redefined word so they'll use
these words that are
emotionally triggering yeah true i think
wherever
anybody right or left or center is and i
mean and that's why your other example
is such a pertinent one
my other example is the one from the
simpsons of the the famous speech
uh you know by the aliens you know when
my my fellow americans when i was young
i dreamt of being a baseball but we must
move forward not backwards upwards not
forwards twirling twirling
towards freedom you're not saying
anything but it gives you this rush
right this tremendous rush it's
evocative it's catchy
right it's it's super salient to you and
i think wherever uh political discourse
is retreating to
things that are super salient to us
without any articulated defended like
understanding of the truth claims that
we're making in terms of them
yeah i think we're we're falling into
both of them so how do we prevent
ourselves from falling prey
to [ __ ] maybe it starts with
identifying it i'm not sure
well i mean part of it is that but part
of it well part of it is to do this
right one of the arguments i make one of
the applications i make of frankfurt is
that
we we can use it as a powerful way of
understanding self-deception and this is
actually
what we're already discussing we're
discussing the ways in which we fall
into patterns of self-deception
and this is again why these levels are
important to me because
like for for very deep reasons you can't
really lie to yourself you
like you know because because beliefs
don't work that way pick a belief you
want to have you can't just believe
right believe yeah i would like to
believe that you know that everybody
loves me i can
imagine that but i believe it
belief doesn't work that way right and
so you you can't really deceive yourself
by lying to yourself but
what you can do is you can [ __ ]
yourself because of the way attention
alters
salience right so if
something is sailing like if there's a
loud noise over here it catches my
attention
remember the catchiness but i can also
use my attention to make something
salient like
look at this right and so notice what i
can do i can
use my attention to make something
salient and then
that is what the advertiser's doing
right and then that makes it more likely
that it will catch my attention
and then right and then i get a feedback
loop yeah a feedback loop
very much a feedback loop and that's how
you can [ __ ] yourself you can
lead yourself onto so let's say you're
addicted to chocolate so you
and you have chocolate on your dice
that's very apropos for me i i've had to
give up
eating chocolate uh for health reasons
so so let's say let's say your
chocolate's in there man okay let's say
you're addicted to chocolates yeah
and you want to not eat chocolates but
you keep it on your desk
that makes you more likely to eat yeah
because this is one of the ways in which
people
fall into self-deception many people
have what's called the cons
the restraint bias they believe
right that they are capable of a lot
more self-regulation
and because they they believe in the
truth of i shouldn't eat the chocolate
that's enough right no it's not in fact
that's
that's the fallacy and so what they'll
do is they'll subject themselves
to the temptation and then they'll find
that they're eating the bloody chocolate
precisely because this chocolate is
salient and without even realizing it
often
they'll start eating the chocolate i
want to stop using my phone so much and
you're telling yourself
that as you're looking at your phone